hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're in round
three of the 2015 Norway chess
tournament we're going to be featuring
nakamura playing the white pieces facing
off against fabiano caruana planned up
black pieces these are two of the top
four players in the world nakamura
currently ranked number four and fabiano
playing the black pieces that currently
ranked number two macklemore's has been
on terror he's essentially one every
tournament he's played he qualified for
the candidates tournament in the Grand
Prix so he'll be playing next year with
an opportunity if he wins that to go on
and face magnus carlsen for the
championship which would be extremely
exciting especially being an American
it's been a while since an American was
at kind of that top level or kind of
challenge for the World Championship so
I think that would be exciting
especially for the press around the
States but today we have an exciting
match against Nakamura and Caruana so
we'll go and get into it Nakamura starts
out with Knight to f3 Knight f6 Ponce e4
pawn c5 so we're getting into not only
the English opening but we're also
getting into the symmetrical English
Defence which we don't see all that
often but always good to see new
openings especially a high level play
that aren't super common Knight c3
knight c6 pawn here to a g3 and then
pawn to d5 Fabio decides he wants to go
ahead and break things up right now he
could if you wanted to continue to just
play pawn to g6 if we see Finn keto here
we could continue to think it over here
to g7 and set besides okay I want to go
ahead and break things up a little bit
and starts with pawn to d5 we see
capture on d5 recapture and then Bishop
here to G to fianchetto pawn here to g6
so now getting ready to Fink head of his
own a bishop here to g7 we see castle on
the King side and then fee and head over
here to g7 now night's going to take
here on d5 and now the Queen comes out
pawn here to d3 these are all kind of
the main lines so not too much new stuff
going on here this is all pretty
theoretical castle on the King side of
Bishop here to e3 now this is a place
where white has
a few options his bishop is protecting
this pawn here on be too so he could
make an argument to keep his bishop here
on c1 one of the options you get after
you play pawn here to d3 is you can now
play your night up here to g5 since it
is protected by a bishop right here on
c1 and this allows you to be somewhat
aggressive on the King side of black
nakamura decides to go against that
plays Bishop e2 e3 I really like Bishop
here to f4 I think it's maybe a little
bit more aggressive but he prepared the
line Bishop here to e3 that's completely
fine as well fabiano plays Bishop here
to these seven I another line just so
many different options in this but
Bishop to be too seems pretty
interesting to me now the roofs going to
come here to be one and then we could
see just the bishop come back here to g7
that seems like an option now Queen to
a4 just some of the possible moves you
could see Queen back here to d6 knowing
that there could be discovered attack if
this night moves here opening up the
door for this light squared Bishop
Knight here to g5 possibly all this I
think is going to be completely okay for
black up and material by one pond giving
white a little bit of a advantage as far
as attacking blacks kind of playing
defense kind of just bringing all those
pieces back as white continues to attack
but does have that pawn in material up
instead fabiano decides to go ahead and
play just development game Bishop here
to d7 so paying somewhat respect to his
opponent knowing that Nakamura if he has
just a little bit of breathing room on
the attacking front he can usually take
that and turn it into a big advantage so
it doesn't want to get too involved it
doesn't know what Nakamura is kind of
prepared for this opening so it kind of
plays it safe plays Bishop here to d7
now night to d4 always interesting move
i love these small little bishop here to
e3 so that it protects the night here on
d4 the Knights being attacked all over
the place by the Queen by the pond by
the night here by the bishop but none of
these can take the night because this
pesky little bishop here on g2 is
attacking the Queen and this queen is
also protect
the night so the Queen can't take it
right here so although everything is
pretty much attacking this night it's
going to be safe right now because the
Queen has to move so the Queen's going
to come up here to d6 and now the
night's going to move it has to move its
being attacked by so many pieces
especially this pawn right here so then
the bishop is going to take here on c6
lying down this Bishop and we do see an
exchange here on c6 so both sides not
trying to get too crazy pretty much
getting material off the board right
here getting into the middle game
approaching the in-game and for all we
can tell it's pretty much equal right
now no one really has an advantage both
sides have the dark squared bishop both
sides Queen double rook almost the same
pawn structure as well so for the most
part it's deadlock right now now if we
look at this board state we can start to
think about what white options has he
could always get his Queen involved into
the game it doesn't want to get into
involved to a force and to be attacked
but maybe queen here to be three this
does protect this pawn here on b2 that's
one option could always if he wanted to
be a little bit more aggressive with his
Bishop right here but right now can't do
too much might as well just attack this
pawn here on c5 as other option that he
has is to start to activate his rooks
rooks are always going to do well on
open files if there's no ponds or also a
semi-open file meaning that your own
pond is not on that file but your
opponent's is and so it allows you to
really aim down put a lot of pressure on
your opponent and that's what nakamura
does brings his rook over here to see
one activating it on the semi open file
attacking this pawn here on c5 black
just it's kind of a nuisance just to
have to worry about this Rick right here
now if we kind of look at black black on
the D file has its own semi-open file so
eventually he will get one of his rooks
here on the eight so we can
counter-attack here on the semi open D
file now from here the Queen's gonna
come over here to a6 attacking this pawn
it would be a mistake if the bishop came
down here and attacked on be too because
then we could just have the rook up here
to see five forcing this Queen to move
after the Queen moves
all of a sudden pawn to d4 this Bishop
right here is trapped and it's just very
very frustrating for black now but I can
look at and say okay but this pawn here
is now free so I'll just come down here
get my queen involved I'll take care on
82 but they're just very very tough for
black all this I've been queen here to
a2 or 2d to this bishop can't move
because then the Queen's going to fall
the Queen has to say somewhat close or
the bishops going to fall say the Queen
comes here to a3 still trying to hold on
to it as well rook down here to see to
attack in the bishop the bishop could
move now the rug gets involved attacking
this pawn up here on b7 just threatening
so many squares rook appear to a6 trying
to hold on to both the bishop now and
the palm but is somewhat overloaded all
of a sudden rook here to see one we
could have bishop or pawn here to be
five work over here to a2 and you're
going to see material fall for black so
this is going to be bad sometimes people
always say you know hey on what about
that move 14 couldn't have the Queen
just take in on a two so thought i would
on certain situations kind of go through
some of the lines to show actually know
if the bishop takes here on b2 that's
going to be extremely bad but black this
that's good and play Queen here to a6
attacking this pawn here on a two and
now the Queen's can come up here to be
three activating a little bit needs to
get involved into the action and also
protecting this pawn here on a two now
black plays pawn to d6 just solidifying
this pawn chain and let's again look at
what white can do he already has this
semi open file kind of controlled by his
rook he could activate this little more
could always bring in here to see to to
see for doesn't want to bring it to c3
since it would be killed by the bishop
but c4 seems reasonable that be a
somewhat aggressive play could always
move around his queen but he just got
here to be three protecting this pawn so
probably not going to be doing too much
with that could always bring his rook
over here to d1 this is a move that I
like activating your rooks in the middle
board and then pushing pawns forward is
always a game plan that usually works
out pretty well in this particular case
we see Nakamura play rook here to see
for getting ready to be pretty
aggressive now the
other Ripken's swing behind it on the
semi open file your rooks connected are
always going to be a good thing now
we're cover here to d8 as we said before
fabiano needs to kind of counter attack
and getting your rook involved to the
other semi open file that black ass is
going to be a good idea Luke over here
to see one as we mentioned work you to
d7 getting ready to do the same thing
double barrel with the rook here on d
eight so both game plans right now we
can kind of look at it in for the most
part guess what they're going to do
there's not too many creative moves
there's no knights on boards we have to
worry about anything too crazy both
sides have the same bishop pair but
they're really kind of blocked off they
can't really do anything too much all
the opponents have to do is keep their
rooks on the opposite colors and they
don't have to worry about too much the
queens are kind of blocked off right now
on the Queen side of the board said
they're not going to be doing too much
so for the most part right now we're
going to see pretty straightforward
moves getting into the in-game
potentially see some exchanges or some
crazy sacrifices and potentially go into
the in game in a somewhat draw a state
if we get into kind of a rook and bishop
or a rook in game we'll just see how it
goes so we're over here to d8 the kind
of double-barreling on the D file look
over here to f4 attacking this pawn here
on f7 also opening up the door for the
other rook to come here to see for if
nakamura wants to a bishop ear to f6
kind of blocking this off pawn to h4
this is kind of the first hey were
pushing forward from nakamura he really
from the very beginning after that pawn
here to see for in the English opening
he stayed pretty passive with his pawns
which is completely fun this is kind of
the first point where he says okay we're
gonna start pushing forward we're gonna
start pushing forward on the King side
and let's see what happens fabiano plays
Queen to be seven now look here to see
to Queen up here to be eight rook down
here to f3 just kind of moving pieces
solidifying their structure a little bit
more not doing anything too crazy route
down here to d5 just more of a
centralizing square right here bishop
here to g5 and then queen to d6 I think
black is may be better served taking the
bishop right here in the actual game
after queen to d6 we see the bishop take
the Queen can't recapture because of the
rook here and so black has double pawns
on the F file usually not something you
want to have going into the in game it's
not nearly as bad on the C file de or F
I'll if you have double ponts much worse
if you have it on you know I'll say H or
the a file so it's not the worst but if
we kind of look at that compared to if
the bishop takes here on g5 and then
maybe kind of it in between move pawn
here to e4 threatening this rook if you
know the bishop takes first and then we
recapture this rooks going to move this
is going to be completely fine for black
has kind of been opening right here that
he can get to later but all in all I
don't see a lot of goodness that white
gets out of this I think this is fine
for black in the game though fabiane
decided to go ahead and give himself the
double ponds and wanted to kind of keep
open up both of these central squares
the d file and the e-file for his rooks
and his Queens if he wants to so Quinn
over here to a4 pond down to a five kind
of stopping that attack create over here
to f4 opening up the door for an
exchange if fabiano wants it fabiano
does not want it right away first place
pawn here to f5 and then we do see in
exchange off the board so this is a rook
in-game things things are pretty drawers
here I you know two of the top players
in the world it's tough to expect much
except getting to kind of a draw in game
here but rooks at the in game especially
with a ton of pawns on board it's very
difficult for anyone to get into vantage
usually the only way someone's going to
win is if they can get their rooks
behind enemy lines so if you can get
your rook back here on like the
seventh-ranked you can kind of chase the
King around tie up your opponent's rook
to protecting ponds instead of being
behind and supporting their own pawns
pushing forward that's really going to
be the only way but with so many ponds
it does look like this is headed
or a draw in game for sure rook up here
to f4 rook to d4 we do see an exchange
on board so making it a little bit
easier to navigate around instead of not
having to worry about two rooks now just
one brook both sides are going to
activate their kings kings as we talked
about in mini-games once your opponent
has their major pieces off the board
especially their queen and one of the
rooks for sure you can always centralize
your king not in too much trouble these
pawns aren't really going to be putting
too much pressure on the king so use
your king as a powerful piece to attack
your opponent kind of push those rooks
away from some of those central squares
king is definitely a huge piece in the
game king here to f6 pawn here to e3
forcing the rook back King to f3 king to
e5 kind of more of the centralized for
fabiano he's kind of beating nakamura to
the punch as far as the middle of the
board but both sides again are going to
have a tough time really doing anything
as far as breaking through pawn a five
or a for king here to d5 came back here
to e to see a few more moves as we kind
of come back here King here to see three
just navigating a little bit pawn to b5
pretty interesting move from fabiano to
go ahead and offer in exchange right
here King here to be five this does open
up the door a little bit it is going to
be somewhat difficult for knocking more
to take advantage on the King side to
get his rook over here but fabien looks
like even though he only has two ponds
he's gonna try to be somewhat aggressive
you could play rook to a seven that's
going to be very good and start to put a
lot of pressure over here pushing his
pawn forward can always get his King
involved as well and then if there is an
exchange you can just come down take
with this rook and then get behind enemy
lines so that's what fabiano is looking
for we first see pawn here to be three
and then a pretty interesting move so
we're in move 40 and fabiano is getting
short on time and he plays pawn here to
g5 and what's interesting is there's
these small little moves
specially an in game where it's a very
small minor mistake but it's actually
has huge consequences and what happens
is after pawn here to g5 because he has
a lot of different options we already
talked about rook here to a7 that makes
a lot of sense supporting this pawn
pushing forward that to me is going to
be my go-to you can always play pawn
here to h5 just kind of clog up the
board there's no reason via fabiano
probably has a little bit more of an
initiative is more of a centralized king
he does have in my opinion a more active
rook if he wants to but pawn here to g5
kind of flips the script after pawn
takes here on g5 and pond recaptures on
g5 then rook here to h1 is very very
dangerous all of a sudden there's no
real way for black to stop this coming
up here and getting involved into the
action now in the actual game the works
can come over here to a7 a little bit
too late and then reappear 2h7 this is
exactly where Nakamura wants to be in
behind enemy lines attacking this pawn
now of a sudden this pawn can't move
this rook is kind of tied to it which he
really wants to be tied to this pawn
here on a 5 but even if we come back
let's say the pawns going to come here
to f6 instead so you know the route
can't come here to age 7 but what it can
do is just come back here to age 8 and
then maybe rook here to be seven because
the Rick was threatening here to be
eight but now of a sudden rook here to
f8 attacking this pawn now depending on
where a black goes why it's just going
to be a nuisance back here you can kind
of just move his rook back and forth and
all in all it's going to be a easy game
for nakamura to kind of control this
since he has now the aggressive piece so
if we come back here after the rook
comes over here to a7 rook appear to h7
we do start to see a few exchange off
the board and then pawn pushing up for
to e4 this is another reason why
Nakamura is pleased that there's no
pawns on the son of the board and he now
has both his deep on in the e pond and
he is pushing those bad boys as fast as
possible pun appear to a 4
reducing exchange off the board so
Fabien does get a little bit of counter
play he has a rook on the queenside but
Nakamura just has too strong of an
attack rook here to f7 threatening this
pawn this rook is going to chase the
King around but all it's really doing is
allowing Nakamura to get his King in a
better spot so King to f3 is really good
spot work over here to d2 but then all
sudden rook to d7 is a great central
square for the rook also protecting this
pond right here King c6 rook here to a
d5 a nice outpost with this pawn right
here always fun to see outpost on your
rook late into the endgame it just
doesn't happen very often so it's a
treat to actually see it in a high-level
game came here to be 6 pushing forward
now once the King comes back we're going
to see the real come back here to d6 and
nakamura can just continue to do the
same thing keep his rook here on the D
file protecting this pawn and then just
continue to push up with the e-file pawn
this King can never get past the chasm
of the D file because the rook here all
in all it's going to be a lost game the
King can come up here to f4 at any time
if you wants to you know assuming he
doesn't want this rook to come over here
to f2 but so many threats that Nakamura
has fabiano is forced to resign in this
situation just way too far behind
recognizing that there's no real way to
stop this pond from pushing forward so
Nakamura as always he's on a tear
everyone that comes in his way he is
just destroying on the chessboard it's
exciting to watch so really enjoy this
he's in first place right now tied with
two and a half points after three
matches so congratulations to him on
another well fought victory hopefully
you guys are enjoying this really
interesting match I thought two of the
top players playing in a somewhat
different opening somewhat the same
since English symmetrical but then
getting into the end game with a very
very small minor mistake that all of a
sudden turns into a pretty easy in game
for one of the top players in the world
so everyone thanks for watching I'll see
you guys in coverage of round for
tomorrow